vous regardez rtl
je voulais en d'accueillir lors alone
oui voila je sais que rtl recherche sans
arrêt des nouveaux talents
et puis donc là on va demander de venir
et de faire une petite chanson pour les
missions de - j'étudie super c'est
l'occasion de faire passer un message
vous êtes une radio génial vos émissions
en tout pour plaire quand je vous écoute
je me régale vos animateurs sens super
vous savez je suis humoriste et je
cherche une place en radio pour me faire
connaître du public remplir les théâtres
les plus gros vous êtes la plus grande
des stations un vrai symbole de qualité
alors je profite de ma chanson pour
faire mon voeux de nouvelle année
aux france inter
rango chez moi ben ouais c'est chez vous
rtl c'est trop tôt
pour moi j'suis pas une esprit d'enfant
car
j'accepterai mais mathieu nault
fmi shalom radio
mais s'il vous plaît sortez-moi dia
je peux pas piffer régis mailhot
j'ai en arrivant au studio de maisons
m'a dit rentre chez toi ça sert à rien
de faire ta promo pour des gens qui
finiront pas le moi j'ai dit pourquoi
touati pavani m'a dit moi c'est pas
pareil je piquais la place de stéphane
et j'aimerais bien me guèye vieille
europe 1 sortez moi de là
à nikos appelle moi viens me sauver
tu sais ici les viols
meurt pas
ils font de grosses têtes pour
l'éternité
il ya 38 fois le nom de là
radio et qui sur les murs en couleurs
on croirait que c'est pour l'ate échos
mais tout le public à alzheimer
je vous parle même pas de laurent
ruquier ce gros comme ça va quand j'ai
peut-être pas d'affaires parce que j'ai
quand même envie de passer dans on n'est
pas couché
et puis il ya stéphane qui préside
id patrice m'a dit pour rigoler
qui ressemble à un spermatozoïde
au moins ils me donnent envie de percer
merci